Tony good morning can you say something
nice about the Cleveland Browns today
well I can Dan they they have some
talent especially on all offensive got
some pieces on defense I do not think
they'll go on 16 that's just as hard to
do as going 16 and 0 so I think they're
going to win a couple games here down
the stretch and if they can get some
consistent quarterback play whether it's
the tail end of this year or next year
they're going to be okay if they have
the number one pick in the draft should
they take a quarterback you know I
haven't seen the college quarterbacks
this year I don't I don't know who that
is if there's a an Andrew Luck Peyton
Manning Tom Brady I think you definitely
have to take them if not there there's
some different ways they can go but and
and this league if you don't have that
franchise quarterback it's always a
struggle so I think anytime you have the
number one pick you have to look for
that yeah but if you can't find it it's
always dangerous if that guy like Jared
Goff with the Rams you know if you find
somebody you think is worthy of that
number one pick but then maybe they are
not up to being that number one pick
franchise quarterback now you set
yourself back a couple of years yeah you
can't create it they did that with them
cows you know they've done it before and
we can we've seen it if that guy's not
there and usually you can recognize and
I don't watch enough college football to
know if that guy is there this year but
you know Andrew log Peyton Manning you
could see it coming out so hopefully for
their sake that guy's there if not you
can do a lot of different things just
get yourself a great player but what
what does the quarterback have to have
who was going to play for you now you
were lucky yet Peyton but you know you
also had some lean years to with Tampa
with Trent Dilfer and but who's the guy
what do they have to have the trait that
is just no matter what they're a good
quarterbacks who who can win games for
you and you're going to be fine but that
special quarterback when you look at
them there's a poise factor and being
able to process information and there's
an accuracy factor if you're accurate
and your poise that's what's
gonna make you a franchise quarterback I
saw where Tony Robo has not been
activated they got the Steelers and the
Cowboys coming up this weekend he's been
medically cleared to play looks like
he's going to be able to go through
practice this week unscathed but why do
you think they're not activating him I
saw this in 1998 I was coaching staff of
eight bucks and my good friend Danny
Green was coaching the Minnesota Vikings
Brad Johnson had taken them to the
playoffs and Brad Johnson's a good
quarterback he got hurt and Randall
Cunningham stepped in and then he said
you can't lose your job by injury as
soon as Brad's ready to go he will be
back in the lineup Randall Cunningham
got hot as a firecracker and that doctor
just seemed to not put brad johnson at a
hundred percent so long Jenica say not
quite he's almost ready and as Randall
through for more touchdown passes he's
almost ready he's almost ready and they
went 15 and 1 you can't take a guy out
who was playing as well and this is this
hot so they're doing the right thing
with Tony Romo take your time now you
may need it Prescott may hit a slump
something may happen but you're on an
eight or nine game winning streak it
really doesn't make sense take the
quarterback out but the role that the
coach plays here Tony now granted Jason
Garrett in Dallas is not really the head
coach it's Jerry Jones and he's also the
team physician and everybody else but
but I mean all Jerry Jones has say is
you know Tony's not ready yet and then
we don't have this controversy but once
he dresses and if he struggles and it's
a home game then I want to see how the
fans react to putting tilma Tony Romo
back in there so that well and that's
what you have to do when he's when you
chill captain that he's ready to go you
dress him and you say he's going to be
there dex build a quarterback but you
know we've got a great quarterback in
the wings Don Shula did that remember
that undefeated season you know uh Bob
Griese got hurt or moral was hot hey
we're going to stay with him stay one
but eventually when they needed it
Gracie was back in they won the Super
Bowl and everybody's happy so you ride
it out it's tough to replace that hot
hand
and that's what as a coach that's what
you've got to do go to Tony Romo's
you're great this doesn't say anything
about you we still have confidence in
you but we're hot right now so I'm not
going to disrupt this as soon as we're
not hot we can put you back in the
lineup would you put Romo back in when
he is cleared to play if you were
coaching the Cowboys I would not put him
back in if that Prescott is still
playing like this and they're on an
eight or nine game winning streak I
would say we've got to ride this out and
until the league figures out that
Prescott we if we win the next 12 games
in a row that's just the way how it's
going to roll he's Tony Dungy football
night in America analysts joining a Stan
Patrick show I talked last hour about
Rex Ryan and Bill Belichick reportedly
voting for Donald Trump some players the
locker room will it be divided
african-americans and what they think of
Donald Trump white players what they
think of Trump as the head coach what
would your role be right now in either
discussing this or distancing yourself
from it now it's as we kind of talked
about this ban with a Colin Kaepernick
situation whatever comes up in life you
can't let it divide the team and I don't
have to think exactly like you think
there's this 40 of 53 guys I guess on
the team not practice squad players is
150 people in the building where all the
family we're all in this together on the
football field and nothing can separate
that but I have to be able to live my
life and do what I feel is right and
think the way I think and yeah we can
have discussions and we can talk about
why you like this candidate and I like
that candidate but at the end of the day
Colin Kaepernick has to be able to have
his say Rex Ryan has to be able to have
his say Bill Belichick same way but then
when we come together and go to work we
go to work as a family and and I don't
think it'll be disruptive at all yeah I
think once you step on the field all
that's put to decide here's my question
for you if I'm a free agent do I want to
play for Rex Ryan if I'm
african-american and I have a problem
with people voting for Donald Trump is
that something that could come out let's
say you're going to the White House and
players say we don't want to go to a
team doesn't want to go to the y
else can you see situations if you're
doing that you're very Sela in my
opinion yeah I have my opinion about
presidential candidates and the last ten
presidents that it doesn't matter when
we're talking about our football team
and to me our football team ghosts of
White House that's one of the perks that
you enjoy whether i agreed with george
bush or Barack Obama or Donald Trump hey
we're going we're representing our city
going to the White House representing
our country it doesn't matter who the
president is hey feeling I'm feeling
good I'm excited about this weekend I
think we got some big games looking
forward to this November December
stretch we don't have a dominant team
you know Dallas is seven and one new
england seven and one but i don't think
either one of those teams are dominant
to me it's going to be a lot of fun
seeing who kind of works through this
and and comes through in december and
january i'm looking forward to it more
of an MVP candidate Ezekiel Elliott
organic Prince gun the quarterbacks
always are the MVP can if they keep
rolling like this as much as Elliott
does for this team and I do believe if
they put Tony Romo back in the lineup
and they played the same way they're
playing now high percentage passes
features a running game take the 42nd
clock down protect their defense they
will continue to win with Tony Romo
because I think Elliott has that much of
an impact but if you had to vote today
you'd have to say dak Prescott because
quarterbacks always get that dead look
would you hold it against brady that he
was suspended for four games when it
comes to the MVP i would not because a
couple of years ago people got mad at me
when I voted for Bobby Wagner yeah as
the MVP Seattle was struggling on
offense they turned into them the best
offense under student they were
struggling on defense they turned into
the best defense in the league when
wagner came back they went to the Super
Bowl so I thought he was the most
valuable player Tom Brady they played
the buffalo bills and got shut out with
Jacoby Brissett same team everything
else the same but Tom Brady come back
they scored 41 points that's
valuable to me so right now I'd say
they've got the best team Tom Brady is
the most valuable part of that team he
would get my vote right now Thank You
tono see on sunday all right looking
forward to it defeat that's Tony Dungy
football night in America Coaches Corner
brought to you by Continental Tire
you'll see Continental Tire at sporting
events venues around the United States
proud supporter of the EMSA racing Major
League Soccer also college basketball
Continentals premium products available
at leading independent tire dealers car
dealers mass retail companies across
America for more information visit
Continental Tire com Continental Tire
for what you do the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience